England's first national child gender
reassignment clinic is being sued by the
mother of a patient and a
psychotherapist used to work there they
claim that experimental treatments used
on children as young as 11 have not been
researched enough they're asking the
court to ban the Tavistock Center from
prescribing hormone blocking medication
unless the court decides it in the
child's best interest
they also accused the clinic and the
trust that it's in charge of gender
identity services in North London of
giving families and misleading
information about the risks of treatment
Marcus Evans a psychiatrist who worked
at the clinic and the husband of the
psychotherapist suing the facility
argues that the treatment is indeed
under researched there's a controversial
treatment with a vulnerable group of
kids it's got long reaching consequences
we really don't know what's going on in
this area and yet the trust was acting
as if there was nothing to look at
everything was fine and we just carry on
as normal
I've never been against people
transitioning I'm just against young
kids making decisions at all their
parents making decisions on their behalf
I couldn't as a parent make a decision
like that on behalf of my children now
how do you talk to a 12 year old about
the implications of their treatment for
their when they're 25 when they might
feel like a completely different person
the clinic however denies the
accusations claiming a high level of
satisfaction from patients despite the
controversy around the treatment the
number of referrals to this clinic has
increased exponentially in recent years
Mark Evans again believes the topic of
gender dysphoria has become highly
politicized and and the well-being of
patients is overlooked something about
this area is highly politicized which
means there's a sort of thing you can't
ask questions all you're accused of
being transphobic and actually normal
medical practice is not taking place in
my view there's not enough research
there's not
interesting the downside what's going on
there's not enough scrutiny of the of
the issue of consent and I think we need
an independent regulatory body that
would oversee this controversial area
and my view is the Trust is too involved
with the pro-trans lobbies it's not it I
don't think it I don't think necessarily
realizes to what extent the political
forces are driving what's going on in
this area
you